la première question donc thermostat
varès le président de peugeot citroën
créé la polémique avec sa rémunération
qui a doublé l'an dernier pour se hisser
à 5 millions deux cent quarante mille
euros est ce que vous êtes choqués voire
plus
écoutez c'est évident que le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça surprend
une telle augmentation que c'est sur
dimensionné notamment par rapport aux
négociations salariales qui viennent
d'avoir lieu dans le groupe psa je
rappelle que l'accord s'est fait à 1,25
pour cent donc on est loin tel écart
donc c'est vrai que c'est une une
augmentation qui choque ça c'est évident
ceci étant regardons aussi la manière
dont les choses se font quand je dis la
manière dont les choses se font ça veut
dire que c'est le mode de rémunération
des présidents de ces entreprises qui en
cause celle là où d'autres au niveau
international quand les présidents sont
non seulement des salaires fixes
importants mais également intéressé au
rendement financier des actions
vis-à-vis des dividendes quand on arrive
à ce type de situation alors que dans
l'automobile serveille bah oui ou plus
aux puces rues selon carlos ghosn et du
deux roues chez daimler et c'est le mode
de rémunération c'est le mode de fûts de
financement et de rémunération qui pose
problème
le mode de rémunération il est indexé
sur la réussite de wii u ne rend patron
or il a assez troublant siens avant ton
bon compte et v6 a prévu à l'avancé
avant son prédécesseur avait fait un
gros travail je vous rappelle philippe
vara avait fait un travail important qui
étaient poursuivis a eu un autre plan
qui a été lancé par monsieur tavares
ensuite dans la foulée c'est vrai que le
groupe à de meilleurs résultats je
rappelle aussi que nous avons signés
force ouvrière et d'autres organisations
un accord pour aider l'entreprise à un
moment donné on n'a pas accepté de
baisse de salaire ni de mobilité forcée
mais il ya eu des efforts de réaliser
par les salariés ce qui est normal
puisque les entreprises allaient dans ce
sens fait je vous écoute vous ne jetez
pas du tout la pierre
véronique cantin cible sur un individu
quel qu'il soit il ya un problème de
rémunération de l'ensemble des
présidents de ces sociétés quelle
qu'elle soit ceux des multinationales et
ça tant qu'on ne réglera pas ce problème
en orage ce type par exemple 5 millions
d'euros pour voir ce fait c'est un
problème battant les bacs et enfin il a
pas beaucoup qui gagnent ça non mais
c'est bien c'est évident mais c est ce
que ces réformes et en noir on se rend
même pas compte de ces problèmes ce mode
de raids ces rémunérations d'une manière
générale sont disproportionnées mais
pour tous les présidents de
multinationales alors soit parmi les
actionnaires de psa il y à l'état tant
qu'etat qui a d'ailleurs approuvé les
mesures qui entrent en vigueur
aujourd'hui au bénéfice de monsieur
carlos tavares mais l'état et qui a voté
également contre cette rémunération
mais est ce que l'état ne montre pas
surtout en ce moment son impuissance et
est ce que vous le regrettez il a une
participation dans le capital est l'état
de l'état n'est pas majoritaire c'est la
paix ça c'était il était intervenu dans
le capital comme d'autres intervenants
extérieurs et l'entreprise sauvée pour
sauver l'entreprise donc l'entreprise
est reparti 1 avec des efforts qui ont
été faits par les salariés je le redis
comme chez renault c'est la même chose à
l'entreprise est reparti également et la
construction automobile se porte pas
trop mal
pas trop mal en ce moment est ce que
pour vous carlos tavares est un bon
patron saint patron qui pour le moment
tous les cas n'a pas licencié
on a une entreprise qui fonctionne un
beau être en bac c'est peu dire quoi bon
patron singes si vous voulez des
appareils affiché solo a pour le moment
où un bilan mais oui mais attendez un
bilan c'est pas c'est pas l'homme
providentiel non plus je dis bien
l'entreprise avait commencé son
redressement avant il ya eu des réformes
de structure avec la famille avec
l'intervention de l'état des
interventions extérieures donc il est
dans une logique de développement de
l'entreprise matin ça justifie pas
maintenant que n'importe quelle
rémunération
alors c'est peut-être trop facile de
passer à la question de la rémunération
des fonctionnaires après ce qu on me
dirait l'instant le gouvernement a donc
annoncé une hausse de 1,2 pour cent ou
trouver l'argent selon vous coûter
l'argent posé dans quelle situation
aujourd'hui les très mauvaises vous le
savez oui elle est très beau il ya des
améliorations du côté de belvèze fois
les améliorations du côté de bercy je
demande à voir
1 parce que la diminution du déficit
c'est aussi dû au fait qu à moins
d'investissements notamment du côté des
collectivités territoriales donc c'est
pas forcément une bonne nouvelle parce
que qui dit moins d'investissements dits
des problèmes de croissance dit les
problèmes du des problèmes d'activité
alors bon écoutez la rémunération qu'on
considère insuffisant je rappelle que le
calcul fait par les fonctionnaires fo et
d'autres organisations c'est dire la
perte de pouvoir d'achat est la hauteur
de 2 8 % pas complètement contestées
vous le savez par le gouvernement par la
cour des comptes qui de son côté la fête
de leur d'achat sur le point d'indicé
revoir la règle générale la wii no
matter lectionnaire la prod point
d'indicé oui non mais quand vous tenez
compte de l'ancienneté quand vous tenez
compte des promotions etc
c'est la voiture c'est toute la
différence entre une négociation en
masse et une négociation en niveau 1
c'est toute la différence lève nous on a
toujours syndicalement défendu les
négociations niveau quand les employeurs
y compris l'état n'est négocié en masse
il regarde sur l'aspect comptable et
budgétaire à ses deux deux visions
différentes de la négociation à l'heure
où l'état peut-il trouver selon un
médecin les deux milliards d'euros
annuels de cette hausse du point
d'indicé d'abord cela se faisait d'abord
s'il faisait une politique économique
différente qui à mener plus d'activités
plus de croissance plus
d'investissements il conçoit - dans une
logique de serrer les boulons comme on
le fait depuis des années il y aurait
des marges des marges de manoeuvre
ensuite comme je lé indiqué plusieurs
fois on feu il faut aussi revoir le site
par exemple système des aides publiques
aux entreprises vous savoir que sur
trois ans est le fondement
même de la politique économique y est
suivie actuellement oui c'est pour ça
qu'ils se plantent parce que les
résultats c'est quand même pas terrible
les résultats de la politique économique
une bonne partie des résultats le
chômage progresse mais les ans le petit
bout de croissance qu'on a un deux ou
qu'on aura cette année
il est essentiellement due à des
éléments extérieurs plus qu'à des
éléments puisque à des éléments
intérieurs l'irl à la baisse de l'euro
l'euro c'est plus ça qui génère de la
croissance qu'autre chose bon mais je
rappellerai que alors vos plaques sans
aucune mais l'orientation des web
c'est un des éléments sur trois ans
cumule le cicr plus le pack de
responsabilités ça fait 100 milliards
d'euros vous rappelez du queen's le
monsieur gattaz 100 milliards d'euros à
millions les 100 milliards ils vont les
avoir sur trois ans cumulés le pin s'il
ne met plus un d'ailleurs parce que le
million d'emplois jamais vu bailat il
est comme son père quand il avait promis
à 25 ans quatre cents soit 4 cents mille
enfants les a jamais vu non plus donc
c'est pas qu'il y ait des aides aux
entreprises on ne conteste pas vous
voulez mais contrepartie réelle en
termes oui mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
que ce soit en emploi ou
d'investissement faut que ce soit des
aides ciblées
j'ai essayé d'expliquer maintes et
maintes fois madame aime conneries ce
qu'était la hiérarchie des normes
visiblement le sa ronde pas où je me
suis mal expliqué où elle a pas compris
hein faut bien comprendre que quand on
le sait la philosophie générale du texte
c'est ce que nous contestons c'est un
des points que nous contestons on est en
train de glisser d'un système que je
qualifie mois républicains au sens on
assure un minimum d'égalité de droits
par des négociations de branche au
niveau national faire un système on
donne la priorité à l'entreprise comme
niveaux de négociation résultats de sari
gelin expliqué dix fois vingt fois mais
bon il n'ya pas pire sourd que celui qui
veut pas entendre les pays qui ont fait
ça l'espagne par exemple quatre ans
après qu'est ce qu'on constate de 12
millions de salariés couverts par les
conventions collectives on est passé à 7
millions connaît le portugal c'est la
même chose vous prenez l'allemagne
on est descendu à 60 % de couverture
conventionnelle c'est une logique qui
est une logique libérale au sens et que
nous aller encore plus loin en disant
c'est une logique anti républicaine ah
bah oui parce que la république liberté
égalité fraternité ca / amy l'égalité
c'est quoi l'égalité républicaine s'est
assuré un minimum d'égalité de droits un
minimum c'est pas l'égalitarisme
comment on assure ça en terme de travail
on assure sa part des conventions
collectives nationales dans la
métallurgie la chimie la banque
vous avez des règles qui s'appliquent
dans l'ensemble du secteur après on peut
négocier dans l'entreprise là sur toute
une série de points en matière de durée
du travail la branche saute on passe
directement l'entreprise
prenez les heures supplémentaires demain
dans une entreprise on pourra dire baal
est sous pression de l'employeur parce
qu'il y aura un problème on paiera les
heures sup les premières à 10% et
l'autre à côté dire ah bah nan moi ce
sera 12 et après ce sera 15
donc on va accroître les inégalités
c'est déstructurant c'est la france et
premier pays au monde en termes de
couverture conventionnelle grâce à notre
système le gouvernement quand même déjà
pas mal reculé
la cfdt finalement soutien 30 à la salle
était ce sont ce qu'on appelle des
coucous savez ce que c'est les coucous
c'est ce qu'ils vont raconter new by
coucou c'est ce qu'ils vont dans le nid
des autres pour pondre leurs oeufs et
les bons alors s'il ya eu 110 cas là
c'est la guerre bah oui parce que moi
quand on m'attaque je réponds que ce que
je veux dire par là il ya eu quelques
petits reculs pour le moment mais la
philosophie générale n'a pas changé
ayant encore toute une série de points
très lourds très importants qui sont
condamnables et qui constituent des
régressions sociales c'est pour ça que
ça va quand je dis au premier ministre
au nom de fo il ya quelques semaines au
début du débat quand ça monte suspendez
votre projet de loi il dit un report
c'est une suspension junon c'est pas la
même chose
un report vous décalez quinze jours une
suspension vous mettez pas de calendrier
n'est pas pour le statu quo il faut que
les choses évoluent mais au moins qu'on
discute du de tous qu'on mette tout sur
la table
il ya un refus à partir de là ce qu'on
veut c'est effectivement on se mobilise
pour retirer le projet de loi à leur
mobilisation justement c'est jeudi
ouais vous pensez que vous serez combien
dans la rue où l'on rappelle mme stead
entre 250000 et 500 milles et seul entre
la police et les manifestants les
organisateurs je ne sais pas combien on
sera plus nombreux
oui je pense qu'on sera plus nombreux
mois enfin je mesure ça en tous les cas
ce qui me remonte au sein de force
ouvrière des départements des
entreprises etc
il ya parfois des entreprises qui se
mobilisent pas et beaucoup et qui là
sont prêts à se mobiliser il ya des
arrêts de travail qui sont déposées donc
je pense qu'on sera nombreux oui et si
on est nombreux et dans tous les cas de
figure il y aura une suite
et du côté des jeunes on a vu que le
mouvement étudiant la semaine dernière
c'était un peu essoufflée est ce que la
wii mais c'est logique si vous voulez on
s'attendait à ce qu'il ya un petit
essoufflement va du côté des étudiants
c'est pas nous qui décidons pour les
étudiants toutes les semaines ça rythme
ça rythme un mouvement mais vous verrez
je pense que le 31 ils seront nombreux
dans la rue c'est du cynisme de faire
appel à la jeunesse selon emmanuel
macron puisque vous ne les protège et
services car il est drôlement verdino ah
oui et il a dit vous avez vu à cannes ya
quelques semaines on ne protège pas les
jeunes au travail avec ce genre de
manifestation on les protège du travail
oui non mais enfin ça c'est les formules
écouter emmanuel macron ca libéral donc
lui y croit il ya la loi va pas assez
loin pour lui donc si il croit que je
sais les jeunes de l'unef ou les études
des lycéens c'est ils ont des consignes
qu'ils reçoivent de je ne sais qui mike
plant c'est tout qui regardent la vie
c'est simplement il se décide tout seul
les genoux
est ce que vous êtes toujours oui je
n'ai jamais caché
alors je suis ni acheter ni acheter non
plus parce que si j'ai été un soldat du
parti socialiste ce ne serait pas dans
cette position je prendrai la position
de laurent berger sur la loi rondeurs
non même pas je suis syndicaliste
comme mes prédécesseurs qui avaient
cette carte aussi que ce soit bergeron
que ce soit blondel voilà maintenant je
ne m'en mêle pas c'est mon droit à titre
individuel je ne m'en cache pas parce
que c'est pas secret et ceci étant ça ne
m'empêche pas et comme disent certains
au gouvernement c'est nous c'est toi qui
nous emmerde le plus bas oui c'est une
preuve d'indépendance et lille où ils
s'étaient tous n'ont peut-être pas tous
les arbres mais vous savez on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une carte parti
socialiste pour être d'accord avec le
gouvernement regarde et leurs bergers
alors le groupe
le gros chantier en parallèle de cette
loi c'est les négociations sur l'unedic
mais l'a finalement on va pas trop
avancé puisque on a surtout parlé c'est
d'un semaine du statut des intermittents
il ya des propositions il ya un accord
qui se dessine entre le medef et la cfdt
et puis les propositions pour que l'état
paye une partie des économies qui devait
être fait
est ce que c'est un modèle que vous
approuvez est ce que vous pourriez
soutenir cet accord non on le on signera
pas cette ce morceau d'accord que les
choses soient claires qu'il faille faire
des économies etc on est d'accord on est
prêt à discuter là dessus mais pas à la
hauteur de ce que veut le patronat et la
cfdt apparemment parce que six ans ça va
jusqu'à 185 millions sur deux ans + 185
millions sur les deux années qui suivent
alors que c'est même pas dans la période
de l'accord ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que demain il ya plus d'un
an exclues tandis que ses équivalents
aux cdd
donc ça veut dire qu'on remet en cause
ses annexes 8 et 10 et en plus dans un
régime paritaire gérée conjointement
patronat syndicats c'est nous qui
appelons les l'état à la rescousse et
demain on va demander à l'état qui siège
aussi à l'unedic
donc c'est remettre en cause le
paritarisme alors si c'est ça on ne
signera pas on ne signera pas cet accord
à 185 millions on était prêt à avancer
mais nous on veut pas demandé de
l'argent l'état je rappelle que l'état
doit mettre 100 millions dans un fonds
non pas pour le chômage mais pour
l'emploi c'est qui est un élément
important
alors maintenant les choses sont claires
s'il a qui veulent signer ce truc bailly
signeront ce truc et puis on verra ce
que ça donne derrière les économies et
vous-même en fait c'est sa grille mais
dans tous les cas de figure il ya des
économies à faire et on est prêt à
regarder les choses il ya des ah bon on
est prêt à regarder autour de 100
millions d'économies mais pas où tu mets
sur deux ans un mets pas ça
cuts à cela on est prêts à discuter là
dessus on l'a dit clairement on a même
fait des propositions en la matière mais
la 185 me enfin attendez on a un medef
qui se radicalise qui fait qu'il veut
faire pression y compris sur le
gouvernement par rapport à la loi par
rapport à son problème bon que des
syndicats suivre c'est leur problème
mais si longtemps nous si c'est ça
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
d'emmanuel macron le libéral où elle
aimerait c'est un libéral je vous
rappelle qu'on s'est rencontrés au salon
de l'agriculture
ouais mais il est avec le libéral mais
attendez moi je fais toujours la part
des choses il ya deux mots essentiels
dont le comportement des uns et des
autres le respect et la confiance c'est
vrai on va dire qu'on est d'accord quand
on est en désaccord ça c'est la
démocratie
mais c'est pas une raison je parle et ap
dessus non le bonhomme en plus
humainement il est sympathique on peut
discuter même quand on est en désaccord
de fond et ça nous arrive régulièrement
mais il respecte confiante à 11 que je
ne tolère pas c'est le manque de respect
ou le manque de confiance
y compris à mon égard c'est le cas par
exemple de la cfdt si j'ai bien compris
parce que depuis tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que vous tapez ce serait cool
ils attaquent moi je réponds le lien de
confiance est cassé ah oui depuis les
retraites complémentaires il est cassé
moi j'aime pas qu'on me raconte des
histoires c'est fini avec apprendre au
maire charles pas où et avec la cgt en
revanche pendant l'avent faut dans ce
programme ou au temps des noms on va pas
se pacser sais pas quand je dis pas que
c'est les deux organisations c'est pas
possible d'ailleurs l'histoire le nid
soir ne nous permet pas on est très
différents les uns des autres là on est
dans une unité d'action
ça pourrait être avec d'autres il ya
d'autres organisations 1 mais à un
moment donné c'est pareil respect
confiance maintenant rêver aussi
critiqué tout à l'heure jean marie le
guen pour toutes les mèches qu'ils
allumaient alors il ya des secrétaires
d'état aux relations avec le parlement a
dit récemment qu'il y avait trop de
syndicats en france est ce que c'est un
avis que vous partagez vos également
écouter ou presque on avait fait une loi
sur la représentativité pour auxerre ce
qu'ils avaient accepté pour qui on est
moins bien pour le moment c'est parra
ici on a toujours autant m'attendais moi
j'ai toujours dit c'est les salariés qui
décident de leur organisation
maintenant c'est pas la peine d'en faire
une dizaine quoi il y en aurait moins ce
serait peut-être pas plus mal à laisser
pas une loi qui change sa sont les
salariés
bien sûr jean claude mailly est ce que
vous comprenez ce qui re voter françois
hollande en 2012 et qui disent
maintenant c'est fini je me détourne et
j'arrête 2017 ou ailleurs il est arrivé
et le bourget on est là récupéré séisme
je vais vous partagez cet avis mois et
se positionne piron plus sain entre nous
le pacte de responsabilité cpd si vous
faites partie des déçus mais moi je n'ai
vous savez beaucoup j'ai voté moi non je
ne sais pas mais là il fait pas
guy lendemain en poche quand même on
peut se vend des gens savaient rien
alors bien sûr on n'en savait rien non
mais non je le dirai pas et en plus
c'est pas parce qu'on a une carte que
voilà senna ça n'a rien à voir pas
obligatoirement en tous les cas comme
étrange de voir je défends la défunte
titre personnel c'est mon problème c'est
pas mais à titre syndical je défends et
je pratique la dépendance syndicales
tous les jours et je vous assure que
parfois c'est pas simple et que peut
être que l'année preuve
vous imaginez tenez un résultat de
présidentielle avec au deuxième tour un
candidat de droite ou de gauche j'en
sais rien quelle que soit l'étiquette le
front national est alors alors présenté
là on est plus en 2002 je rappelle qu'en
2010 on n'avait pas donné de consigne de
vote ne sais pas moi j'étais
secrétaire-général et je vais m'appuyer
cette position parce que vous donnerez
pas en 2017
aucune en aucune façon on dira ce qu'on
a à dire sur les positions et c'est
parce que je vous rappelle que ça fait
trois ans trois ans que j'explique
régulièrement et je les dis au président
de la république je l' ai dit à
plusieurs reprises que la logique
d'austérité ou de rigueur d'appel ça
comme on veut c'est suicidaire
socialement remet en cause des droits
économiquement ça plombe la croissance
et démocratiquement vous vous laisserez
faire et que j'ai fait pour que je
laisse faire
si moi je me bats 1 et quand ce congé
dit au président de la république
concours à la conférence sociale que
l'une des raisons du monte en france
comme ailleurs monsieur quand je discute
avec mes collègues européens
vous avez ça dans les pays nordiques
vous avez 100 belge et vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end en belgique
mais quand je l'essentiel pour nous des
raisons c'est quoi c'est une situation
économique et sociale en france comme
ailleurs
donc si l'on en est tous d'accord ce
n'est pas tous d'accord qui doit quand
je dis ça mais walgreen alaric me répond
non c'est essentiel c'est un problème
identitaire
vous voyez qu'on n'a pas la même analyse
d'accord mais donc si effectivement il
ya un duel entre le front national et un
candidat de gauche ou de droite parce
que ne prendrait pas position en 2020
nous dirons ce que nous avons à
disposition la donne pas de consigne de
vote formel comme on l'a fait en 2002 et
vous a su observer altre indépendant
c'est pas simplement un coup de temps en
temps pour faire plaisir l'indépendance
syndicale est pas donné de consigne de
vote
c'est aussi dans les moments où c'est
pas s'arrêter là vous n'arrêtez pas de
parler de la des valeurs de la
république depuis 2000 bien solution à
propos de la loi travailler vos nous dit
qu'en cas de duel entre le français
demeurer un parti dit républicain
bravo
rien on dire ça veut dire pour les
positions en finlande en 2003 appelait
de consigne de vote formel non d'abord
quel titre un syndicat donne une
consigne de vote
les gens ils font ce qu'ils veulent dans
l'isoloir